raw loud and uncompromising Jennifer
Rostock have gone back to their roots
with their new single organs bossest
Emmer
how much sun afternoon doom let's know I
think that after the last album which
was a bit more introverted let's say
we've taken our fists out again to get
back to the boisterous rebellious
feeling of the early days it's not
melancholic it's life-affirming with a
feeling of get up and do something
for instance get up and do something
against right-wing nationalism and the
alternative for Germany party that is
gaining ground in the country after
Jennifer Rostock posted their protest
song on Facebook it was played 15
million times within a week - ish
everything is an inspiration to us
everything we experienced discussions we
have with each other or with others
what's going on around us everything we
get wind of lands here and then we turn
it around a bit and it ends up in the
music we make and then was even Jennifer
Rostock started out playing in small
clubs in 2007 but their mix of punk
alternative rock and electro soon found
a bigger fan base
in the beginning we played 150 to 180
times a year you could hear us in every
small town that's where we started we
began playing small stages lots of fans
and took them with us to the big stage
and in 2009 they played at Brandenburg
Gate in Berlin on German Unity Day in
front of over a million people
and they just keep getting more popular
their 2014 album sloth lows reached
number two in the German charts
this one's on the networks Thunder boy
we've become a little bit more grown-up
we don't drink as much before our
performances we're more responsible now
of course people pay real money for our
concerts and of course we want to
deliver we want to give them a good time
we don't want them to go home and say
what was that all about they may be
drinking less but their image is still
of maladjusted punk rockers in their
video for once cared enough actors play
the band members partying through the
night in Berlin
let's get out it's about experiencing a
high enjoying the moment and celebrating
the night let's get but it's also about
something else let's go home with some
the pizza it's about what we need to do
to be happy
what's important to us de carros do we
need big cars and status symbols or are
other things more important
Kazuko for Jennifer Rostock it's clear
life is about having fun making music
and standing up for your ideas
you